just a simple point when you see this
inverse string function in there
right you know that you can't play the
simple algebraic game that you can play
in the first question
you've got to do something else now
the standard answer is well guess what
this guy doesn't like to play the
algebraic game
but we can make him because there are
things that we know about taneverse
that can turn him into standard algebra
that we can deal with
right think of all the things you've
learned in maths over the last two years
right here's how i'm going to begin i'm
going to say
let y equal and i'm going to define this
now the reason why this is useful is
because if i prove this is greater than
0
you can catch that this is a constant
theme in inequalities it's easy to prove
that things are positive
because we know lots of things about
positive things if i can prove this
thing is positive
that this is greater than zero then i've
proved this does
so how do i prove that this is positive
how do i make it play with algebra well
you differentiate right because then
what is the derivative of this let's
have a look x
differentiate you get one okay here
what's going to happen
um you got chain rule happening right so
i see there's a minus here and there's a
minus
there so the derivative of the inside
function is
negative one so it's going to cancel
these is that okay so i'm going to put a
plus there
right and then what's the regular way
that you differentiate ten inverse
it's one on one plus
this square one plus this
squared okay so far so good there's the
derivative
so in other words this tells me how this
is behaving
i need to show that this is greater than
zero without oops sorry
without the boundary and then i've got
this result
okay for this particular domain so how
do i do it
how do i use a derivative to show that
something is always going to be positive
let's think about things that are always
positive right
if you had something nice and neat like
say a parabola right you could get the
discriminate
you should you could say the
discriminant's negative and the leading
coefficient is positive
and up it goes right but oh i don't have
a
quadratic so clearly not the
discriminant right
what other kinds of graphs are always
positive
oh you could now oh so close
if you had if you had this it's not
always
positive i have the boundary there so
this is a dot okay
but we're overthinking it right if i
have a graph that looks like this
right it's a bit random but if it's oh
sorry
let's just smooth that out a bit if it's
increasing if it's increasing and i know
at some point
you know over here that it's going to be
greater than one and all i'm
i've got a fairly restricted domain here
right i need all real values
then then i'm done look see if i have
this point here
and this is the domain i'm interested in
look it's positive
so what do i need to establish about
this derivative
to show that it's increasing
to show that this is greater than zero i
need to show
that this is greater than zero this is
very very simple
okay there's a couple ways you could do
it you could appeal to the discriminant
of this guy
right because look positive positive if
this is positive
they're all positive right a simpler way
to do it though is just go algebra
right let's put these two together this
is two fractions
right so i'm going to go 1 plus 1 minus
x squared plus 1
over this denominator right
well that's just two isn't it okay now
have a look at all the pieces
have a look at all the pieces i've got
two and one
pretty sure the last time i checked they
were positive right
but i also know this other piece right
one minus
x squared right in this domain look not
inclusive of one
not inclusive of one that's important
that's greater than zero
so i've got all of these positive pieces
right so therefore the derivative
in the domain that i'm interested in is
always positive
so i've established it's increasing
now of course increasing is not enough
right because if i have this
this is increasing but look it's got a
whole chunk of it that's negative
so what must i establish
i need i need some value i need some
value right i need something like this
or something like this right and look at
what our domain is it's x is greater
than one
so if i take the boundary
right if i can show that at that point
it's above the axis
and then it's just going to increase
from there it's never going to come back
right
when you put this into here you get y
equals
1 minus tan inverse of
0 which is 0 so you get 1
right so now i have a picture right at x
equals 1 y equals one
and the derivative tells me it's
increasing from then on
so it's always above the axis
and since why i define to be this right
therefore okay i'm running out of space
x minus 10 inverse so that thing
is greater than zero and now you just
move the other guy over
now that's the standard way that's the
standard way when you see trig don't
panic
right particularly inverse tree because
inverse tree just disguises algebra and
we can deal with algebra just like we
did before